and I tell you what happened to me last
week I have to talk about it go ahead so
I really show called magnum p.i
do you call it Magnum yes you can't do a
one-off so I show up and this is my
fourth one I mean Hawaiians and in the
morning I see I see Robocop the Robocop
yeah Peter Weller yeah who's a teacher
now professor yeah yeah he's a doctor
he's a dog you have to call him dr.
peter weller
[Laughter]
actually if you're dead you're not
coming with me you call the mortuary
yeah so I'm on set he's rifts I've done
er amazing and that was very good that
was but it's weird because this is a
group of comedy people and how many
people do that sometimes something's
funny I love how self-conscious you get
you're killing the [ __ ] game right
now shut the [ __ ] up aromatic dictator
you know that kim jong hoon Kim Jong Il
yeah there was a story about how he
hired he hired a sushi chef right and
then the sushi chef wrote like an op-ed
and for I don't know where but he said
that he would go on jet ski races with
his employees or with his right-hand men
and if you beat him in a jet ski race he
would shoot he would shoot you and kill
you like right then and there but if you
didn't pose a challenge he would also
shoot and kill you Wow there was a very
delicate balance of having to kind of
give him a good race but not quite win
oh my god to push him to his best but
not beat him I don't really like those
guys the PC police are gonna get me on
this one but I don't I'm not a huge fan
of those guys so go ahead so go back to
[ __ ] so that's crazy
but that's you yeah it's like that
normal okay so you would do that when
North Korea when North Korea right when
went to the World Cup right and they
lost to Portugal 8 to 1 right the
[ __ ] coach of the North Korean team
had to work at a mining Jesus
get it carry rocks for a month back and
forth yeah anyway so I'm on set early in
the morning it was on Magnum soompi I
you know I don't like your tone why
because it's not Silicon Valley [ __ ]
you [ __ ] killing the game alright
anyway I do bid parts and network to
your television [ __ ]
anyway um in the morning I I'm directing
I'm a huge fan cuz I saw him in that
Star Trek movie and he walks up to me
and he this is what he says don't [ __ ]
this up what was his opening line
Robocop yeah and he walked away [ __ ] is
going on right I did one so I did one
tag right and I hear hot and then he
goes right and now I thought person
would ever say that to Bobby Lea and I
fart and poke like little boobs coming
sorry yeah fear pues fear food yeah it
was this show after Fear Factor yes I
would fart right and my Chinese Crested
and the stars of the show are good
friends of mine now perdida and Jane
right he's necessary she is he's great
he doesn't meet you know this is Robocop
yeah Robocop and all week long he was
like that so that the last day of
shooting I had one line
I couldn't even say I just cuz I just
didn't want to be there we're gonna take
a quick break to share some amazing
sponsors with you Brooklyn n-woo do you
like softness comfort essentials to help
you relax Brooklyn